this video was made possible by story
blocks click the link in the description
below for an exclusive seven day free
trial and download professional footage
photos vector graphics and more for your
next project
we humans have always had a fascination
with the idea that perhaps were not
alone in the universe
as far back as ancient Greece we have
records of philosophers considering the
existence of an infinite universe
populated with countless other
civilizations if we simply look at the
probability of other life-forms existing
somewhere in the depths of outer space
it's apparent that we should be one of
tens of thousands of civilizations in
the Milky Way alone but to this day
despite all our searching we have yet to
find any evidence of extraterrestrial
life one potential explanation for this
lack of evidence is the possibility that
humans simply aren't advanced enough to
detect the existence of other
civilizations when astronomers probe the
void of space searching for life they're
not looking for a planet full of little
green men but rather for the tell-tale
signs of advanced technology when
considering what kinds of technology
these extraterrestrials would have
scientists group their civilizations
into three overarching types based on
their energy consumption type 1 type 2
and type 3 this grouping is known as the
Kardashev scale and it offers a useful
if speculative tool for classifying
extraterrestrial civilizations a type
one civilization is characterized by its
ability to harness the entirety of its
own planet's resources from fossil fuels
to geothermal energy to wind essentially
anything their planet does that produces
energy a type one civilization can
control and harness a type two
civilization has graduated from the tiny
amounts of energy a planet can provide
and has moved on to harness 100% of the
energy of their mother star this energy
is used to power massive machines and
space vessels when a type two
civilization eventually exhausts the
power of their star they move on to type
3 harnessing the power of billions of
stars over an entire galaxy technology
at this level would be so advanced that
we humans would most likely be unable to
comprehend it so where do humans fall on
the scale well technically we're not
even on the scale humanity has achieved
about 70 to 75% of type 1 status so we
are still classified as type 0 however
many scientists predict that we will
achieve type 1 status within a century
or so this transition will be one of the
most significant steps in human history
and there are people alive today who
might live to see it
what will the type one version of
humanity look like while speculation
varies from person to person most
experts agree that a type one
civilization would be a global society
with the world's cultures far more
integrated than they are today in the
past cities or countries would mostly
keep to themselves but with the advent
of different forms of transportation
people were able to move more freely
between cities and countries and their
respective cultures even today we can
see the beginning of this global
civilization rather than hundreds of
independent countries representing
themselves we have economic bloc's like
the European Union and NAFTA within
which individual countries may dislike
some of their Co members but work
together for the benefit of the whole we
can see that world culture is becoming
more universal almost everywhere you go
in the world you'll find the same luxury
brands similar musical tastes and
recreational activities we have global
sports competitions such as the Olympics
and various world series which stands in
contrast to historical competitions that
took place between local groups or
tribes rather than foreign nations the
Internet has allowed us to communicate
ideas with unparalleled freedom and the
spread of information is instantaneous
creating a worldwide network of news
media and cultural trends a type one
civilization will likely have a common
language in today's society many
educated or wealthy people speak English
in addition to their native tongue which
leads many to speculate that English
will become the global standard language
allowing for even easier communication
between nations as this new world
culture develops economies will flourish
will likely experience an overall
increase in quality of life and the
scientific discoveries of nations
working together should pave the way to
greater and greater technology
eventually allowing humanity to progress
to a type two civilization of course
even though we're witnessing the first
baby steps toward a multicultural type
one civilization there are a number of
serious obstacles to overcome if
Humanity is to succeed there are groups
that are absolutely opposed to a global
society these groups pose a major threat
not only to the birth of a type one
civilization but also to the continued
existence of humanity the proliferation
of nuclear weapons and the fact that
they've fallen into very dangerous hands
represents perhaps the biggest stumbling
block to global advancement
the reason for such resistance to
building a global society is motivated
either by radicalism or an outright
hatred of the commingling of Western
culture with other parts of the world
the reason for this is that isolationist
or radical philosophy stands in direct
opposition to the characteristics of a
type one civilization characteristics
such as tolerance multiculturalism and
investment and trust in science so while
it's not guaranteed that humanity will
be able to jump these hurdles and emerge
a fully fledged type one civilization we
seem to be laying the groundwork and
moving in the right direction only time
will tell if humanity as a species is
bound for even greater achievements
among the stars look at this number
that's a lot of money specifically
that's the amount of money I would have
spent on my videos if I had bought stock
footage from a traditional stock site
luckily for me I'm able to get all my
stock footage from story blocks story
blocks is the first and only stock media
company offering unlimited free
downloads of member library content for
a modest annual fee with a story block
subscription you'll also have access to
the marketplace an awesome feature
four-story blocks members that gives you
access to millions of digital assets
that are continually contributed by
artists from around the world the
marketplace is a la carte and prices
start as low as 399 for full usage
rights of images and $49 for video and
100% of the sales revenue goes directly
to the artist since I started using
story blocks this past April I've
downloaded 205 stock footage clips from
the member library to use in my videos
thanks to my membership every single one
of those 205 clips cost me $0 had I
chosen to buy stock footage from other
sites I would have had to spend over
$16,000 to produce my videos and that's
something most creators simply can't
afford so whether you already have your
own YouTube channel or you're thinking
of starting one but don't have a camera
or if you're in any branch of video
production definitely give story blocks
a try I can easily say that signing up
with story blocks has been one of the
best investments I've made for my
channel and I've used assets from the
member library in almost every video
since getting my subscription if you
want to take your production value to
the next level follow the link in the
description below to start your
exclusive 7 day free trial with story
blocks and download unlimited assets
from the
member library for your next project
this isn't a publicly available trial so
be sure to go check it out
it's a great way to show your support
for second thought and gives you
unlimited access to the story blocks
member library for a full week with no
strings attached
follow the link on your screen or in the
description below to sign up for your
7-day free trial today if you enjoyed
this video remember to subscribe and
click the little bell to join the
notification squad you can binge watch
the rest of my content by clicking here
or if you're in the mood for something a
little different come watch me play
games with a friend on my new gaming
channel thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next video